abdul razak burna es el ganador del
nobel de literatura- 2021 nació en
tanzania en 1948 tuvo que irse a vivir
como refugiado en reino unido a finales
de la década de 1960 su penetración
intransigente y compasiva con los
efectos del colonialismo y el destino
del refugiado en el abismo entre
culturas y continentes lo hicieron el
elegido gobernar james esta desilusión
la mirada de qurna es desilusionada y a
menudo austera y consistentemente
traiciona a nuestras expectativas de
resoluciones fáciles al mismo tiempo es
un observador compasivo de las
dificultades humanas no es menos
memorable en sus retratos de los jóvenes
huérfanos gente bajo presión oa las
mujeres negras en una sociedad machista
con el race east side
el nobel de este año se enmarca en el
cambio que la academia sueca ha aplicado
con miras de bajar el dominio occidental
pues el 81 por ciento de los ganadores
son europeos o norteamericanos
pensé esto es alguien haciéndome una
broma sabes en estos días reciben muchas
llamadas desconocidas y levantas el
teléfono y no sabes quién llama y
alguien te dice has ganado el premio
nobel y piensas o si es el quinto autor
africano en ser galardonado en este
premio y un escritor que no figuraba en
los pronósticos críticos de suecia han
señalado que el asombro de este premio
no era tan grande desde que el chino mo
yan ganó el premio en 2012